PREVIOUSLY
ON "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,"
WHEN THE GIRLS HIT THE CATWALK
WITH MISS J...
ATTITUDE,
STRONG, STRONG, STRONG.
KARI AND DANIELLE
NEARLY HIT THE GROUND.
♪♪♪
THE RUNWAY CHALLENGE
HAD SOME UNUSUAL ACCESSORIES...
(screams)
OH, DON'T DO THIS!
AND JADE
PLAYED ON GINA'S INSECURITIES
ONCE AGAIN.
KISS IT, KISS IT.
WHEN IT WAS TIME
TO FALL ON CUE,
DANIELLE EXCELLED
WHILE GINA FELL FLAT.
OKAY, THAT ONE YOU JUST FELL.
BUT KARI LOST HER BALANCE
AND HER CONFIDENCE
IN FRONT OF THE JUDGES,
AND SHE WAS SENT HOME.
TEN GIRLS REMAIN.
WHO WILL BE ELIMINATED TONIGHT?
♪♪♪
IT JUST FEELS LIKE SOMEBODY,
LIKE, DIED.
IT'S SO WEIRD,
LIKE, KARI'S GONE.
THAT IS SO SAD.
DURING THE LAST ELIMINATION,
I'M ONE OF THE BOTTOM TWO,
IT'S ME AND KARI,
AND WHEN TYRA FLIPS OVER
MY PICTURE...
GINA.
I'M IN UTTER SHOCK.
♪♪♪
I KNOW I CAN ROCK THIS,
BUT WITH WHAT'S GOING AROUND
THE HOUSE, WITH--
ESPECIALLY WITH ME AND JADE...
I DON'T MEAN
TO GIVE YOU CRAP,
BUT SERIOUSLY, LIKE, YOU, LIKE,
TO BE IN THIS COMPETITION, YO,
YOU GOTTA KNOW WHO YOU ARE,
PERIOD.
JADE IS MEAN,
AND SHE'S, LIKE, MEAN TO ME.
KISS IT, KISS IT.
JADE. NO, IT'S OKAY.
I HATE TO ADMIT IT,
BUT, YOU KNOW,
IT'S REALLY GETTING TO ME,
AND IT'S HINDERING
MY PERFORMANCE.
I KNOW I'VE HAD BAD PICTURES,
LIKE, I'M NOT SAYING
THAT MY PICTURES ARE THE BEST.
I HAVEN'T HAD GOOD PICTURES.
I DON'T LIKE ANY OF MY PICTURES.
I PUT SO MUCH PRESSURE ON MYSELF
BECAUSE THEY'RE JUDGING ME,
AND EVERY LITTLE THING I CAN DO,
IF IT'S A MISTAKE,
I CAN BE SENT HOME FOR IT.
(telephone rings)
OKAY, I JUST WANT TO SAY
I LOVE YOU.
MY BOYFRIEND,
HE'S JUST MISSING ME,
'CAUSE THAT'S THE FIRST TIME
WE'VE BEEN AWAY FROM EACH OTHER.
WE'RE HERE WAITING IN LINE
TO SEND HER OFF TO CALIFORNIA.
UM, UM, I WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT Y'ALL TAKE CARE OF MY BABY.
I DO GET ANNOYED WITH JOHN,
AND MY GUT IS TELLING ME THAT
HE MIGHT BE A LITTLE
TOO CONTROLLING.
OKAY, BABY, GO TO SLEEP.
I LOVE YOU.
OOH, MY TOE IS SWOLLEN.
LOOK AT MY PINKIE TOE.
LAST ELIMINATION,
I WAS IN, UH, LIKE,
10-INCH HEELS, AND I TRIPPED.
CAREFUL.
DOING OKAY?
I'M ON "AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL" WITH CRUTCHES!
BUT YOUR ANKLE'S OKAY?
YEAH, MY ANKLE...
I MEAN, IT HURT WHEN I FELL,
BUT IT--IT'S NOT HURTING
RIGHT NOW.
IT'S MY TOE.
I HAVE A REALLY, REALLY
HIGH TOLERANCE FOR PAIN.
I THINK IT WILL FEEL
A LOT BETTER TOMORROW.
TYRA MAIL!
IT SAYS,
"WHAT'S YOUR FAVORITE POSITION?"
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT SEX
TOO MUCH.
- THAT'S WHAT THIS IS ABOUT.
- I KNOW, I KNOW.
(laughing)
♪♪♪
WE WALK INTO THIS BALLROOM...
WE SEE ALL THESE ARTISTS.
AND RIGHT IN DEAD-SMACK CENTER
IS THIS WOMAN
POSING LIKE A MANNEQUIN.
AND I WAS LIKE,
"WHO IS THAT?"
I-I KINDA THOUGHT
IT MIGHT BE A MAN.
GOOD GOD, Y'ALL!
WHO COULD IT BE?
(cheering)
WELCOME TO JANICE DICKINSON'S
POSING CLASS,
WHERE I WILL BE TEACHING YOU
THE FINE ART OF COMMERCIAL
VERSUS EDITORIAL POSES.
WITH ME TODAY IS MISS LISA.
HI, GIRLS.
(cheering)
- HOW ARE YOU?
- LISA KNOWS HOW TO POSE.
THAT'S GOOD. SMILE.
TURN BACK TO HIM.
THAT LOOKS GOOD.
THE KEY ELEMENTS
FOR EDITORIAL POSING
IS LONG, LUSCIOUS, LOVELY.
COMMERCIAL--
HAPPY, PERKY, SKIPPY.
I DON'T KNOW HOW TO POSE.
SHE IS EXPLAINING IT TO ME,
BUT I'M STILL HAVING DIFFICULTY
UNDERSTANDING WHAT
SHE'S MEANING BY IT.
WE'RE GONNA WATCH LISA COPY
WHAT I'M SAYING
AS I'M DIRECTING.
COMMERCIAL MODELING POSES
BEGIN WITH YOUR BASIC
NUMBER ONE POSE, WHICH IS...
STAND ON TWO FEET,
HANDS DOWN,
WAD.
THIS IS WADDING.
WINDING A WRISTWATCH,
LOOKING UP...
THESE ARE, LIKE, TECHNIQUES
THAT YOU CAN MAYBE, LIKE,
CHECKING A BROKEN NAIL
AND LOOKING FOR A TAXI
AND SMILING.
HA HA HA HA HA HA!
IT'S SO FUNNY TO GET A TAXI.
BUT ALWAYS
IN COMMERCIAL MODELING,
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
TO KEEP THE ENERGY GOING
AND THE "HA HA HA HA HA!"
THE ALLIGATOR--
HA HA HA HA!
HA HA HA HA HA!
HI, IS THIS ALL ABOUT
COMMERCIAL LOOKS TODAY?
NO.
SO NOW WE'RE GONNA
GO INTO EDITORIAL.
IT'S ALL ABOUT...
THAT'S GOOD, THAT'S GOOD.
EDITORIAL MODELING IS MORE...
(deepens voice) DIVA.
(normal voice) EDITORIAL POSING
IS JUST ABOUT WEARING A FEELING.
IT'S THE FEELING THAT
THE CLIENT GIVES YOU,
THE PHOTOGRAPHER GIVES YOU,
THE EDITOR GIVES YOU THAT DAY.
YOU HAVE TO FIND THE LIGHT,
WHICH IS WHY I'M CRANING
LIKE THIS.
CRANING FOR THE LIGHT,
ME ALWAYS BEING MORE FABULOUS
THAN ANYONE ELSE.
(laughing) SORRY.
SO WHEN WE'RE WORKING
OUR POSES,
HOW LONG DO YOU SUGGEST THAT
WE STAY IN IT AND JUST GIVE
DIFFERENT EXPRESSIONS?
I CAN'T GIVE YOU
AN EXACT AMOUNT.
IT'S MORE ABOUT FEELING IT.
YOU'VE--YOU'VE GOTTA BE GIVING
THE PHOTOGRAPHER ENOUGH TIME
TO TAKE YOUR PICTURE.
YOU SAY TO FIND THE LIGHT
WITH YOUR FACE.
LIKE,
I STILL DON'T QUITE GET IT.
IT'S ABOUT KNOWING
WHAT YOUR BEST ANGLES ARE.
HOW TO TURN IT AROUND
IS UP TO YOU.
I THINK BROOKE LOOKED MESSY.
COME ON, THIS IS
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"!
SHE SHOWED UP LOOKING LIKE
SHE JUST ROLLED OUT OF BED.
HOW DO YOU GIVE, LIKE,
A CONVINCING--
WHAT'S--WHAT'S YOUR NAME?
- GINA.
- HI, GINA.
HELLO.
I CAN'T GIVE A CONVINCING PHOTO.
- LIKE, I CAN'T--
- I CAN TELL YOU RIGHT NOW
THAT YOU JUST SAID, "I CAN'T
GIVE A CONVINCING PHOTOGRAPH."
- NO, THAT'S THE PROBLEM--
- I DON'T WANNA HEAR
THE NEXT THING
OUT OF YOUR MOUTH, BUT GO AHEAD.
OKAY, WELL, IT'S--I'VE ALWAYS
GIVEN, LIKE, A BLANK STARE.
SMILE.
CAN YOU GIVE ME A SMILE?
CAN YOU LAUGH OUT LOUD, GINA?
(laughs)
THAT'S IT. (chuckles)
GINA, GET UP IN BACK
OF THE GIRLS NOW
AND STAND ON ONE FOOT.
GO STAND ON ONE FOOT.
AND JUMP UP AND DOWN
ON ONE FOOT...
- OH, GOD.
- I'M NOT KIDDING YOU.
- OKAY.
- GO ON, JUMP UP AND DOWN
AND HYSTERICALLY LAUGH AND LOOK
AT ME AND DO IT.
OH, MY GOD.
(imitates Gina) NO, NO,
GOD, DO IT.
(normal voice) COME ON.
HA HA HA HA HA!
KEEP IT GOING.
HA HA HA HA HA...
GINA WAS KINDA CLUELESS.
I WAS JUST LIKE, "THIS GIRL
HAS LOST HER DAMN MIND."
PUT YOUR CHIN DOWN.
HA HA HA HA HA!
I FELT STUPID.
OF COURSE,
JADE IS SO HAPPY AT THIS POINT.
OUT LOUD!
I KNEW JANICE
WAS GONNA GET HER.
I STOPPED LOOKING
BECAUSE IT WAS PAINFUL.
IT WAS PAINFUL FOR ME TO WATCH.
EVEN IF YOU DON'T--
YOU THINK YOU'RE MAKING
A TOTAL FOOL OF YOURSELF,
IT'S A LESSON.
GINA DOES NOT KNOW HOW
TO LAUGH AT HERSELF.
SHE HAS A PROBLEM FEELING
COMFORTABLE AND CONFIDENT
MAKING ANY POSE STICK.
JUST REMEMBER WHO YOU ARE,
BE CONFIDENT AND FABULOUS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
(cheering)
THANK YOU, AND GOOD LUCK.
♪♪♪
(speaking indistinctly)
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"
WANNABES.
(cheering)
GIVE ME A BEAT.
BOOM, AH, AH,
BOOM.
(beatboxing)
COME ON, GINA.
HAVE FUN.
♪ UHH, UHH-UHH ♪
♪ LAUGH, GINA, LAUGH ♪
HA HA HA HA HA HA HA!
WE'RE GONNA JUST KICK BACK.
WE'RE GONNA HAVE FUN.
(cheering)
JANICE IS JUST AWESOME.
WHAT, WHAT?
I'M TELLING YOU.
HOLLER.
ME AND HER KIND OF CLICK
BECAUSE WE'RE ON THE SAME LEVEL.
- GINA.
- YES?
COME ON OVER HERE, GINA.
COME HERE, BABY.
WHO'S GIVING YOU SOME... ?
TELL ME,
AND I'LL GO KICK THEIR ASS.
- DO I HAVE TO?
- YES.
TELL ME WHO'S GIVING YOU...
YO!
YO HO!
WHAT?
WHAT, ARE YOU SERIOUS?
ARE YOU REALLY SERIOUS?
SHE JUST POINTED AT YOU.
WHAT DID I DO NOW, GINA,
SERIOUSLY?
YOU CAN GO--YOU CAN...
WHAT DID I DO NOW?
I WAS THINKING IN MY HEAD
LIKE, "WHAT?!"
FIRST OF ALL,
YOU CAN GET YOUR ASS OFF
AND GO OVER THERE.
WHAT DID I DO NOW, GINA?
YOU CAN GO--
YOU CAN GO AWAY.
GINA, NO MATTER WHAT,
RULE NUMBER ONE--
WE NEVER RAT OUT OUR BITCHES.
- RULE NUMBER ONE...
- NO, NO,
- THE THING IS I NEVER...
- SHH! ZIP IT!
I WANNA EXPLAIN MYSELF
AT THAT POINT,
BECAUSE IT'S NOT FAIR.
THE THING IS, THOUGH, I NEVER--
THERE'S NO "THING."
ZIP IT, BITCH!
ZIP IT.
YOU'RE DEAD IN MY BOOK.
THAT'S JANICE.
YOU KNOW, WHAT YOU GET
IS WHAT YOU GET.
HOLLER!
(all) HOLLER!
AND YOU GOTTA BE PREPARED
NO MATTER WHAT.
♪♪♪
(crying) DID YOU SEE
JADE'S FACE WHEN THAT HAPPENED?
- I KNOW.
- LIKE, SHE WAS SO HAPPY.
SHE DOESN'T DESERVE TO BE HAPPY
AT THAT POINT.
AND IT'S LIKE,
I DON'T KNOW HOW TO HANDLE IT.
I THINK JADE PICKS ON GINA.
I MEAN, 'CAUSE FROM DAY ONE,
GINA'S BEEN KINDA,
YOU KNOW, QUIET.
I DIDN'T WANNA RAT HER OUT,
BUT SHE ASKED ME AGAIN.
WHAT AM I SUPPOSED TO DO?
SHE LET JADE GET IN HER HEAD,
AND SO JADE'S
STUCK IN THERE NOW.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO NOW.
WHAT THE HECK
ARE YOU SCARED OF?
WHAT IS JADE GONNA DO,
SHE GONNA SPANK YOU?
FROM NOW ON,
EVEN IF YOU DON'T KNOW
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING,
JUST LOOK CONFIDENT
SO THEY DON'T SEE YOU
AS AN EASY TARGET.
AFTER THE RESTAURANT,
I'M TAKING A SHOWER,
AND I GET OUT OF THE BATHROOM,
AND I SEE JADE IS ON MY BED.
SHE'S THE LAST PERSON
I WANNA SEE BY THAT POINT.
YOU HAVE GOT IT SO TWISTED.
I DON'T HAVE IT TWISTED,
JADE.
SWEETHEART, YOU DO.
I GET OUT OF THE SHOWER,
AND I SEE JADE IS ON MY BED.
I'M TIRED. I WANNA GO TO BED.
I REALLY DIDN'T APPRECIATE
DINNER.
I THOUGHT THAT WAS SO
UNCALLED FOR.
OH, JADE, I DON'T WANNA...
WELL, WE'RE GONNA HAVE
TO DO THIS NOW, BECAUSE I'M--
- I REALLY WANNA DO THIS NOW.
- JADE, I'M...
I DON'T WANNA TALK ABOUT IT.
WELL, IF WE'RE GONNA--
WHY NOT?
ARE YOU REALLY SHOCKED
THAT I... I CALLED YOU OUT?
- I MEAN--
- I'M VERY SHOCKED.
DO YOU THINK THEY'RE SHOCKED,
REALLY?
AT THAT POINT, I JUST REALLY
NEEDED TO STAND UP FOR MYSELF.
I'M SITTING HERE
TRYING TO MAKE PEACE,
AND YOU'RE TRIPPIN' OUT.
YOU'RE NEVER GONNA MAKE
PEACE WITH ME.
YOU SAY YOU FEEL SORRY FOR ME?
- I FEEL VERY SORRY FOR YOU.
- YOU DON'T UNDERSTAND ANYTHING.
- BUT YOU KNOW WHAT?
YOU THINK
YOU'RE GETTING UNDER MY SKIN,
YOU'RE INTIMIDATING ME.
YOU'RE NOT INTIMIDATING ME
AT ALL.
LIKE, WHY ARE YOU...
YOU CAN SAY WHATEVER
THE HELL YOU WANT, JADE.
I'M DONE WITH YOU.
I'M GLAD GINA
DECIDED TO STAND UP FOR HERSELF.
IT WAS MY BATTLE,
AND I THINK I DID PRETTY WELL.
TYRA MAIL!
"READY FOR A CHANGE
OF SCENERY?"
(cheering)
WE'RE GONNA
GO OUT OF THE COUNTRY!
I'M NOT BUYING IT.
YEAH, BECAUSE EVERY TIME
WE SAY SOMETHING,
IT'S TOTALLY OFF.
♪♪♪
HI, GIRLS. HOW ARE YOU?
(all) HI.
MY NAME IS LAWRENCE ZARIAN,
AND I AM A PROFESSIONAL MODEL.
I KNOW THAT YESTERDAY
YOU WERE EDUCATED ON EDITORIAL
AND COMMERCIAL POSING.
WELL, TODAY YOU'RE GONNA BE
TESTED ON COMMERCIAL POSING.
NOW TODAY WE'RE GONNA BE DOING
SOMETHING FOR SEARS.
AND BEHIND ME,
YOU'LL NOTICE I HAVE
FOUR DIFFERENT SEASONS.
I HAVE SPRING, SUMMER,
FALL AND WINTER,
AND I'VE ALSO PROVIDED
HAIR AND MAKEUP AND WARDROBE.
I WANNA SEE WHICH ONE OF YOU
CAN NOT ONLY GET YOUR HAIR
AND MAKEUP AND GET DRESSED,
BUT ACCOMMODATE EACH POSE
FOR EACH SEASON.
I'M GONNA INTRODUCE YOU
TO WHAT I THINK
IS ONE OF THE BEST PHOTOGRAPHERS
IN TOWN.
PLEASE WELCOME RUSSELL BAER.
WOW.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
PHOTOGRAPHERS LOVE ABOUT MODELS
LIKE TYRA BANKS
IS THAT SHE CAN COME IN,
SHE CAN GET THE JOB DONE
AND SHE CAN GET OUT THE DOOR,
BECAUSE TIME IS MONEY
IN THIS BUSINESS, AS YOU KNOW.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
I WILL BE LOOKING AT TODAY
IS THE FACT THAT
I CAN'T DIRECT YOU.
YOU GUYS
HAVE TO DIRECT YOURSELVES
AND SEE WHAT YOU GUYS
HAVE LEARNED PREVIOUSLY.
AND THERE'S GONNA BE
ONE WINNER.
WE'LL FIND OUT WHO THAT IS
AT THE END OF THE DAY,
AND THE FIRST PERSON TO START
IS JADE.
(applause)
SO IF YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS,
COME ON UP HERE, JADE.
ALL THE CLOTHES
ARE SET UP OVER THERE,
AND WE'LL DO IT, UH, FAST.
- GO!
- GO.
READY FOR POSE NUMBER ONE?
THIS IS IT. GREAT.
LET'S MOVE IT ON,
SEE WHAT WE GOT.
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
RIGHT NOW IS JUST FOCUSING
ON THIS COMPETITION.
YOU'RE GOING REALLY SLOW.
YOU GOTTA MAKE IT FAST.
READY? AND...
FINAL LOOK IS WINTER.
YOU KNOW, I JUST HAD FUN
WITH ALL THE SEASONS
AND, UM, I FEEL GREAT.
I'M JADE, MAN.
LIKE, LOOK AT ME!
♪♪♪
GUESS WHO'S UP NEXT?
MOLLIE SUE!
WE HAD SEARS
DO EVERYONE'S WARDROBE.
ALL THE CLOTHES WERE VERY COOL.
THEY WERE VERY EXCITING,
VERY BRIGHT.
♪♪♪
LET ME SEE WHAT YOU GOT.
HA HA HA HA HA!
(imitates Sara) AH HA HA!
BRING IT IN.
SARA--SHE REALLY DOES HAVE
THE WHOLE PACKAGE.
♪♪♪
ALL RIGHT, THERE YOU GO,
YOU READY?
YEP.
READY, STEADY AND...
BEAUTIFUL.
READY, AND...
THE LAST ONE.
♪♪♪
DON'T FORGET,
YOU NEED TO SELL THE SHOT.
HA HA HA HA HA!
GOOD.
I FELT LIKE, COMMERCIAL,
YOU HAD TO LAUGH A LOT
AND SMILE, SO I WAS DOING THAT.
BUT I...
I REALLY DON'T FEEL
THAT COMFORTABLE DOING IT.
REGROUP,
SHAKE IT OUT A LITTLE BIT.
NICE.
I REALLY HOPE THAT BROOKE IS
GONNA NAIL IT.
UNFORTUNATELY,
SHE'S STILL LEARNING,
AND THE FACE AND THE BODY
JUST DIDN'T MATCH TOGETHER.
♪♪♪
ALL RIGHT, DANIELLE,
ARE YOU READY?
TODAY WE'RE DOING
A PHOTO SHOOT FOR SEARS,
AND MY PINKIE TOE... (laughs)
I STILL LOOK GIMPY, BUT, UH,
THE SWELLING HAS GONE DOWN.
THE STRONG SURVIVE,
SO I'LL BE ALL RIGHT.
- ALL RIGHT.
- ALL RIGHT, HERE SHE COMES.
♪♪♪
I KNOW YOU'RE CONCENTRATING,
BUT IF IT HELPS YOU AT ALL,
YOU ARE ALLOWED TO TALK TO US.
WHEN I FIRST MET NNENNA,
SHE DIDN'T SAY MUCH,
SO THAT REALLY PUT ME OFF.
OKAY, KEEP YOUR ENERGY UP.
I SEEM QUIET
BECAUSE I'M TRYING TO FOCUS
AND THINK ABOUT
WHAT I'M GONNA DO
AND HOW I'M GONNA DO IT.
THE REALITY
IS SHE'S JUST A QUIET PERSON.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THOSE PICTURES,
SHE COMES ALIVE, SHE'S INVITING.
♪♪♪
HAVE YOU BEEN WATCHING
THE OTHER GIRLS?
UM, A LITTLE BIT.
AND... KEEP IT REAL,
BUT KEEP IT WHAT YOU'RE SELLING.
THAT'S IT. LET'S SEE IT. NICE.
♪♪♪
I THINK THE SUN'S COMING OUT
A LITTLE BIT.
COME ON, BRING ME THE HEAT,
SHOW IT.
♪♪♪
WILL YOU PLEASE
BRING US SPRING?
- I WILL BRING YOU SPRING.
- YOU WILL BRING ME SPRING?
I WILL BRING YOU SPRING.
HOPEFULLY, I WON'T LET JADE
GET TO ME ANYMORE
AND RUIN MY CONCENTRATION
IN THIS COMPETITION.
WELL, YOU PROMISED ME
YOU'RE GONNA SHOW ME SPRING.
I SEE THAT ENERGY.
OKAY, YOU GOT IT?
GIVE ME FACE...
AND THERE IT IS,
READY?
WE GOT PROPS FLYING EVERYWHERE.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO,
AND I JUST TRY TO WORK
WHAT I HAVE.
SHOW ME FACE,
AND...
GINA--IF SHE CAN GET
HER POSES DOWN,
SHE COULD BE ANOTHER
REALLY STRONG CONTENDER.
HAVE SOME FUN. I LIKE THAT.
LET'S HEAR IT FOR GINA!
(cheering)
♪♪♪
ALL RIGHT, EACH ONE OF YOU
HAS SUCH A GREAT GIFT.
WE SAW POTENTIAL
IN EVERYBODY UP THERE.
AND THE ONE GIRL
THAT EVERY SINGLE SHOT
WAS A HOME RUN, IS...
NNENNA.
(cheering)
YAY! CONGRATULATIONS.
GOOD JOB, GIRL.
I'M NOT WORRIED ABOUT
NNENNA WINNING THE CHALLENGE.
JUST LET HER WIN THE CHALLENGE.
THAT'S COOL.
YOU KNOW, SHE'S A COOL FEMALE.
JUST... GIVE ME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,
AND I'LL BE OKAY.
THIS IS WHAT YOU GET TO WIN.
SEE ALL THESE SEARS CLOTHES?
YES?
YOU HAVE WON...
ALL THE OUTFITS.
ALL OF THEM.
(cheering)
YOU GET ALL THE OUTFITS.
THIS WIN IS REALLY NECESSARY
FOR ME,
AND I TOLD MYSELF THIS WEEK
THAT I HAD TO DO
REALLY, REALLY WELL
AND CONCENTRATE
ON WHAT I'M HERE FOR.
♪♪♪
SO WHEN WE GET HOME,
NNENNA IS SPENDING
A LOT OF TIME ON THE PHONE.
You don't understand
how miserable it is,
how miserable I am,
not getting to talk to you.
YOU'RE GETTING TO TALK TO ME
RIGHT NOW.
I get to hear from you.
MY BOYFRIEND...
I GUESS I DIDN'T REALIZE
HOW ATTACHED
HE REALLY WAS TO ME.
HE'S ANGRY, HE'S VULNERABLE,
HE'S MISSING ME.
YOU'RE BEING VERY ANNOYING
AND YOU'RE STILL NOT STOPPING.
YOU GO--YOU'RE MAKING IT WORSE.
FOR ME TO FOCUS
IN THIS COMPETITION...
YES, I NEED JOHN TO BACK OFF
A LITTLE BIT.
WE WILL HAVE
ANY DEEP CONVERSATIONS
WHEN I GET HOME FROM...
- First of all...
- AND I'M SERIOUS.
First of all
first of all...
(hangs up phone)
♪♪♪
I THINK I DID THE WORST
IN THE CHALLENGE TODAY.
I FEEL THAT THIS WEEK
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT FOR ME
TO STEP IT UP AND DO WELL,
JUST BECAUSE I HAVEN'T BEEN
DOING WELL IN THE PAST.
I HAVE TO KICK ASS IN MY PHOTO
SHOOT TOMORROW.
MM-HMM.
Y'ALL, WE GOT TYRA MAIL!
"AT 10 YEARS OLD, YOU SAID,
'WHEN I GROW UP,
I WANNA BE A MODEL.'
I HOPE YOU'RE NOT STILL
SAYING THAT WHEN YOU'RE MY AGE.
TYRA."
- WHAT?
- WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
MAYBE WE'LL ALL BE, LIKE,
LITTLE KIDS RUNNING AROUND.
(laughing)
WE'RE JUST TRYING TO COME UP
WITH ALL THESE SCENARIOS,
AND USUALLY,
THEY'RE WRONG ANYWAYS.
I'M LIKE, "THERE'S NO POINT
IN TRYING
TO COME UP WITH ANYTHING."
♪♪♪
(cheering)
OH!
HI!
HOW ARE Y'ALL?
HOW ARE YOU DOING?
(all) GOOD.
- WELCOME!
YOU'RE AT MY SHOW,
AND THIS IS MY DRESSING ROOM.
WHEN I WAS 15, 16 YEARS OLD,
I WANTED TO BE A MODEL,
AND I REALLY DEDICATED MYSELF
TO BEING A MODEL.
BUT AT THE BACK OF MY MIND,
I ALWAYS KNEW THAT
IT WAS A TEMPORARY CAREER.
WHAT I WANNA DO TODAY
IS I WANNA TALK TO ALL OF YOU
ABOUT YOUR FUTURE GOALS,
BECAUSE I WANT TO HELP RAISE
VERY STRONG WOMEN AS WELL,
NOT JUST MODELS.
OKAY?
SO, DANIELLE,
WHAT ARE YOUR FUTURE GOALS?
WHEN I WAS A LITTLE GIRL,
I WANTED TO BE A SINGER.
LIKE, THAT IS WHAT
I WANTED TO DO.
BUT I DO NOT HAVE A VOICE.
ALL RIGHT, FURONDA,
WHAT ABOUT YOU?
I WANNA BE AN ATTORNEY,
AND I WANNA DO MOSTLY
HUMAN RIGHTS LAW.
I WANTED
TO GO INTO CRIMINAL JUSTICE.
- CRIMINAL JUSTICE?
- YEAH.
NO MATTER WHAT, I WANNA STAY
IN THE FASHION INDUSTRY,
UM, WHETHER IT'S EVEN
HAIR AND MAKEUP.
I WAS ACTUALLY THINKING ABOUT
GOING TO DESIGN SCHOOL
FOR A WHILE.
- FOR FASHION DESIGN?
- YEAH.
I THINK IT, UH,
A REALLY IMPORTANT JOB
IS, UM, BEING A MOTHER.
I'VE WANTED CHILDREN
FOR SO LONG,
BUT I FEEL LIKE I HAVE TO BE
AT A PLACE IN MY LIFE
WHERE I'M MORE SETTLED.
I LOVE CHILDREN,
AND I WANNA BE
A KINDERGARTEN TEACHER.
A KINDERGARTEN TEACHER?
YES, 'CAUSE I LOVE KIDS.
IT'S JUST SO RANDOM
TO HEAR JADE SAY SHE WANTS TO BE
A KINDERGARTEN TEACHER.
IF NEED BE,
I WOULD HOMESCHOOL MY CHILD
BEFORE THEY WENT
TO JADE'S CLASS, MM-MM.
I COULD SEE MYSELF, UM,
BEING A PROSECUTOR.
I HAVE A DEGREE IN CHEMISTRY.
I SEE MYSELF
TRYING TO DO DRUG RESEARCH
IN AFRICA.
GOOD. WHAT ABOUT YOU, BROOKE?
I WANT TO BE
A NURSE NECESSITIST.
YOU MEAN, "ANESTHETIST"?
YEAH. (chuckles)
SO YOU WANT
TO PUT PEOPLE UNDER?
BASICALLY.
IT'S NOT SO MUCH
THAT TYRA MAKES ME NERVOUS.
I JUST BECOME REALLY NERVOUS
THAT SHE MAY NOT LIKE ME.
AND BECAUSE IT IS A COMPETITION,
I FEEL THAT EVERYTHING WE DO
IS BEING JUDGED.
WHEN I WAS... I THINK
I WAS 18 OR 19 YEARS OLD,
I DID AN INTERVIEW
IN MILAN, ITALY,
AND I WAS ALL YOUNG AND BUBBLY,
LIKE, "I'M JUST HAPPY
TO DO AN INTERVIEW!"
AND THEY WERE LIKE, "SO, TYRA,
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA BE DOING
AFTER MODELING?"
AND I'M LIKE,
"WELL, YOU KNOW WHAT?
WHEN I'M 23 OR 24 YEARS OLD
I'M-A RETIRE FROM MODELING,
AND I'M-A HAVE
MY OWN TALK SHOW."
SO I DID MAKE
THIS TALK SHOW DREAM COME TRUE,
AND IT'S BECAUSE
I ALWAYS HAD MY MIND ON THAT.
WELL, I JUST FINISHED A SHOW,
AND NOW I GOTTA
GO DO ANOTHER SHOW,
BUT I WANTED TO THANK Y'ALL
FOR COMING.
(all) THANK YOU.
AND SEEING, YOU KNOW,
MY--MY OTHER JOB.
SO I'LL SEE YOU SOON!
(all) BYE.
- (singsongy) BYE!
♪♪♪
SO YOU GUYS
JUST MET WITH TYRA, RIGHT?
(all) YES.
TODAY YOU GIRLS
ARE ACTUALLY GOING TO ACT OUT
YOUR FUTURE GOALS ON SET
IN AN EDITORIAL FASHION.
WELL, OF COURSE,
TO DO AN EDITORIAL SHOOT,
I HAD TO BRING A VERY COOL
EDITORIAL PHOTOGRAPHER.
HIS NAME'S THOMAS.
COME OUT HERE.
SEE, THEY CLAP FOR TALENT.
- OH, THANKS.
- (laughs)
I'M HERE TO HELP YOU
AND MAKE YOU BEAUTIFUL.
THIS IS NOT GONNA BE
SIMPLE PHOTOGRAPHY.
IT'S ABOUT DOING THINGS
THAT LOOK EDGY.
ALL RIGHT.
♪♪♪
I DON'T MIND TO ACTUALLY
CREATE A SORT OF...
- BEAUTIFUL BANGS, YOU KNOW.
- YES, MESS IT UP.
CAN YOU GUYS COME OVER HERE
FOR A SECOND?
I THOUGHT I'D GIVE YOU SOMETHING
TO BRING IN A LITTLE MORE LIFE
TO THE SHOT.
WE'RE THINKING, "OH, GREAT.
WHAT IS IT THIS TIME?
LIKE, SLOTHS OR SNAKES
OR PORCUPINES?"
CAN I HAVE MY, UM, EXTRAS?
- OH, HO!
- YEAH!
OUT COME FIVE
DELICIOUSLY HALF-NAKED GUYS.
(chuckles)
GOT SO MUCH CANDY.
WHEN THEY BRING OUT
THE MALE MODELS,
THEY ARE ALL CUTE,
I WANT TO HAVE FUN.
(chuckling) YEAH!
I'VE BEEN COOPED UP
IN THE HOUSE WITH THESE WOMEN,
WHO ARE NAGGING, P.M.S.ing,
FIGHTING...
SO TO SEE THESE MEN WALK IN,
I'M LIKE, "THANK YOU, JESUS."
GUYS, INTRODUCE YOURSELVES
STARTING DOWN HERE.
MY NAME IS J.T.
(camera shutter clicks)
I'M SKYLER.
- HI.
- WHAT'S UP? I'M VAUGHN.
(camera shutter clicks)
STEVEN.
ZANE.
(camera shutter clicks)
COOL, ALL RIGHT,
YOU GUYS CAN CHAT
WITH THE GUYS A LITTLE.
IT'S SUPPOSED TO BE EDGY,
SO HOW DO YOU MAKE IT EDGY?
YOU CAN BE VERY EDGY, BROOKE.
I DON'T...
I'M NOT VERY IMAGINATIVE.
WHATEVER YOU NEED,
I'LL GIVE IT TO YOU, SO...
- YEAH.
- IF YOU NEED SOME INTENSITY,
- I'LL GIVE YOU THAT.
- EXACTLY.
HE'S GOOD-LOOKING.
HE'S A MODEL,
SO HE'S GOOD-LOOKING, OF COURSE.
I WASN'T MISSING MY BOYFRIEND
AT ALL.
SO WE'LL MAKE IT HOT.
TODAY I AM
A HUMAN RIGHTS ATTORNEY/
BLACK PANTHER.
POWER TO THE PEOPLE.
THAT WAS A GREAT LOOK.
TODAY I USED A LOT OF THINGS
THAT JANICE TOLD US.
LOOKS GOOD.
I THINK MY PHOTOGRAPHS
ARE GONNA COME OUT
REALLY, REALLY GOOD.
I HAVE HAIR,
SO IT'S JUST A TOTAL TRANSITION
TO WHAT I HAVE.
IT ACTUALLY PLAYS
MY VERSATILITY LOOKS.
YOU KNOW, IN MODELING,
IN THE MODELING WORLD,
THE GIRLS THAT WORK
HAVE LONG HAIR.
(laughs)
I AM JUST, LIKE, DAMNED,
BECAUSE I KNOW IN THE INDUSTRY
LONG HAIR IS WHAT SELLS.
SO I'M EXCITED, DEFINITELY.
♪♪♪
READ HIM A STORY.
THAT WAS SO KINDA TWISTED
BUT CUTE.
SEE, IT WORKED.
GOOD JOB.
LOOK AT YOU!
MY LAWYER? NO.
BUT MOST PEOPLE,
THEY WOULD PROBABLY
LIKE THEIR LAWYERS TO WEAR THIS.
I WAS WEARING, LIKE,
THE HIGHEST HEELS POSSIBLE.
I JUST FELT LIKE THE PICTURE
WAS GONNA LOOK RIDICULOUS.
I FEEL LIKE THIS IS PAGE ONE
OF AN EDITORIAL.
PAGE TWO, YOUR TOP'S OFF.
PAGE THREE,
YOU'RE ON YOUR KNEES.
THAT'S THE WAY
IT'S STARTING TO LOOK.
JUST BECAUSE
YOU'RE THE STAY-AT-HOME MOM
DOESN'T MEAN YOU'VE GOTTA PLAY
THOSE "STEREOTYPICAL" ROLES.
LOOK TO CAMERA
IN THAT POSE THOUGH.
ARCH! LIKE, I WANNA--
I WANNA FEEL THAT "UGH!"
THIS IS SUCH A CUTE COUPLE.
WE HAVE MOLLIE SUE.
I GOT TO WEAR STILETTOS.
YOU KNOW, I GOT TO BE A GIRL.
I GOT TO BE A LITTLE MORE ROCK,
WHICH KIND OF PUT ME
IN MY ELEMENT.
GOOD IMPROVISATION.
I JUST WANNA DO WELL.
I'M THINKING
THAT I'M GONNA DO GREAT.
YOU KNOW, THIS IS MY CHANCE
TO SHINE.
IF YOU FLIP THE DRESS,
YOU HAVE TO, LIKE,
BE REALLY FOCUSED.
I GET DISTRACTED SO EASILY.
I LOSE MY FOCUS AND THEN...
THAT'S WHEN EVERYTHING
JUST STARTS GOING BAD.
OKAY, HOLD ON, HOLD OUT.
I DEFINITELY THINK
THAT WHAT HAS BEEN HAPPENING
BETWEEN JADE AND GINA
IS WORKING OUT
TO JADE'S ADVANTAGE.
YOU KNOW, LOOK AT GINA NOW.
IT'S MORE LIKE POSING
THAN MEASURING HIM, YOU KNOW?
I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT
WAS GOING ON WITH GINA TODAY.
EVERY SHOT
WAS JUST SO UNCOMFORTABLE.
ALL RIGHT,
I'M GONNA STOP RIGHT HERE.
I FEEL BAD FOR HER.
GINA'S LOST.
SHE NEEDS TO FIND HERSELF.
YOU LOOK INCREDIBLE,
BUT HE IS STEALING THE SHOT
FROM YOU IN EVERY FRAME,
AND IF I HONESTLY HAD
TO PUBLISH THIS PICTURE,
I WOULD CROP YOU
RIGHT OUT OF IT.
THE FRUSTRATING THING IS,
I KNOW THAT I CAN DO BETTER.
BUT FOR SOME REASON,
I'M JUST GETTING LOST
IN WHAT'S GOING ON IN THE HOUSE,
WHICH IS REALLY
OF NO IMPORTANCE TO ANYTHING.
OH, BEAUTIFUL.
MY THEME
WAS PRIVATE INVESTIGATOR/
DOMINATRIX.
I'M NOT SURE HOW ONE
HAS TO DO WITH THE OTHER.
BEND OVER,
LET HER SMACK YOUR BUM.
WHAT?
MAYBE THAT WAS A FANTASY.
BEAUTIFUL.
ALL RIGHT, DANIELLE.
I WAS NERVOUS AT FIRST,
BUT THE MINUTE
THAT THE CAMERA STARTED,
YOU KNOW, CLICKING, LIKE,
I WAS JUST MOVING,
AND, YOU KNOW,
WE WERE PRETTY MUCH GOING OFF
EACH OTHER'S VIBES.
WE HAVE SO NAILED THAT SHOT.
IT'S, LIKE, ORGASMIC BACK HERE.
TRULY.
SO WHEN YOU SAID
THIS WAS YOUR FUTURE GOAL,
WERE YOU ENVISIONING THIS?
NOT QUITE EXACTLY LIKE THIS,
BUT IT'LL WORK FOR TODAY.
IT'LL WORK FOR TODAY?
GOOD. READY?
DOES THIS LOOK GOOD?
DOES IT SELL AN OUTFIT?
OKAY.
KEEP THAT SHOULDER BACK.
FLIRT WITH HIM A LITTLE. SMILE.
I KNOW THAT
I HAVE THE POTENTIAL,
AND I JUST FEEL THAT
I LET MY NERVES
GET THE BETTER OF ME
IN THIS COMPETITION.
WELL, I REALLY LOVE BROOKE.
I THINK SHE DOES HAVE
A LOT OF POTENTIAL,
BUT HER CONFIDENCE--SHE NEEDS
TO REALLY WORK ON THAT.
WELL,
THAT LOOKS A LITTLE STRANGE.
BROOKE WAS AWKWARD.
SHE WAS NOT COMFORTABLE
IN THE WARDROBE SHE WAS WEARING.
AND AS A MODEL,
YOU SHOULD BE ABLE
TO MODEL A GARBAGE BAG
AND SELL IT TO ME.
SHE DIDN'T DO THAT.
DON'T BE AFRAID
OF CREATING ENERGY AND CHEMISTRY
ON THE SET.
OH, I LOVE THAT.
FEEL THE AFRICAN BREEZE.
IT HELPS WHEN BOTH MODELS
ARE ATTRACTIVE.
HE WAS ATTRACTIVE,
AND I THINK I'M ATTRACTIVE,
SO I THINK THAT HELPED.
OH, THAT ONE WAS HOT.
DID YOU SEE THAT?
ALL THE TOUCHING AND GROPING
AND ALL THE SENSUALNESS...
WHAT?!
ALL RIGHT, NNENNA.
THE SHOOT
GETS PRETTY INTIMATE.
IT WAS LIKE,
"OH, MY GOD."
LAST FRAME.
WORK, DAMN IT.
GIRL!
WAIT, WAIT, WAIT,
BITCH, WHERE YOU GOING?
(laughter)
- WHERE YOU GOING?
WAS HE RUBBING YOU
THE RIGHT WAY?
HE TOTALLY PITCHED A TENT
WHILE THEY WERE IN AFRICA!
(laughs)
AND NOT ONE THAT YOU CAMP IN,
EITHER.
THAT FINALE AT THE END...
NNENNA, YOU MIGHT WANNA
CALL YOUR BOYFRIEND,
'CAUSE I DON'T THINK
THAT'S GONNA BE GOOD.
I AIN'T MAD AT YA, GIRL.
GO ON.
MAYBE IT GOT OUT OF HAND,
MAYBE IT DIDN'T.
I DON'T KNOW,
BUT I JUST HAD FUN
AT THE PHOTO SHOOT.
♪♪♪
HEY, BABY.
Uh-oh. Nnenna?
I FELT GUILTY, AND THE GIRLS
MADE SUCH A BIG DEAL ABOUT IT.
I WAS LIKE, "OH, MAN,
OKAY, MAYBE I SHOULD TELL JOHN."
OKAY, I LIED,
I LIED.
(phone clicks)
HELLO?
NORMALLY,
I ALWAYS KNOW WHAT TO DO,
BUT THIS RELATIONSHIP THING
IS NOT--I HATE RELATIONSHIPS.
HELLO?
♪♪♪
(dial tone)
TYRA MAIL!
"TOMORROW
YOU WILL MEET WITH THE JUDGES.
ONLY NINE WILL CONTINUE ON
IN THE HOPES OF BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
YEAH, THIS IS A SHOCK.
UNFORTUNATELY,
SOMEBODY IS GOING HOME.
FOR REAL,
TO TELL YOU THE TRUTH,
12 PEOPLE GOTTA GET ELIMINATED.
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING?
AND I DON'T WANT IT TO BE ME.
EVERYBODY IS THINKING
GINA'S GONNA GO HOME.
I DON'T THINK
SHE'S GOING ANYWHERE.
THE GAME HAS JUST BEGUN.
I'M TELLING YOU,
THE LAST MAN STANDING IS STRONG.
YOU KNOW? (laughs)
♪♪♪
WELCOME BACK
TO THE JUDGING ROOM, LADIES.
YOU'VE HAD AN INTERESTING WEEK
WHERE YOU LEARNED ABOUT
BEING COMMERCIAL VERSUS
BEING EDGY,
AND HOW IT'S IMPORTANT
TO NOT JUST BE GOOD AT ONE
BUT TO BE GOOD AT BOTH.
YOU KNOW ABOUT OUR PRIZES.
THE FIRST IS A CONTRACT
WITH TOP INTERNATIONAL
MODELING MANAGEMENT COMPANY
FORD MODELS,
A SPREAD IN "ELLE" MAGAZINE
THAT WILL BE SHOT
BY WORLD-RENOWNED PHOTOGRAPHER
GILLES BENSIMON
AND A $100,000 CONTRACT
WITH COVER GIRL COSMETICS.
AND, OF COURSE,
YOU KNOW OUR JUDGES.
THE FIRST IS THE NOTED
FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER
NIGEL BARKER...
THE FABULOUS RUNWAY DIVA COACH
MISS J. ALEXANDER....
LEGENDARY FASHION ICON TWIGGY.
- HELLO.
- HI.
AND LAWRENCE ZARIAN.
LAWRENCE HAS BEEN A MALE MODEL
FOR TEN YEARS.
SO TODAY I WANT TO HAVE YOU
RIGHT NOW SELL YOUR CLOTHES
THAT YOU HAVE ON
AS IF YOU WERE IN A CATALOG.
I WANT YOU TO GIVE ME
THREE CATALOG POSES
WITH THIS LOOK.
MOLLIE SUE, YOU'RE FIRST.
♪♪♪
ALL RIGHTY.
(clears throat)
HA.
(chuckles) SORRY.
♪♪♪
HA HA HA!
ALL RIGHT.
HA HA HA HA!
- (chuckling) OKAY.
- HA HA HA!
HA HA HA!
NOW I NEED YOU
TO DO THREE EDGY POSES
USING THESE ITEMS.
(grunts)
(laughs)
- THERE WE GO.
- WHAT?
♪♪♪
ALL RIGHTY,
THANK YOU, DANIELLE.
♪♪♪
SECOND POSE.
DO I HAVE TO DO MORE
OR JUST...
YOU HAVE TWO MORE EDGY POSES.
♪♪♪
(chuckles)
CAN I WEAR THESE?
GET IN IT? (chuckles)
WAS THAT A POSE?
♪♪♪
(snorts)
(chuckling)
WORK IT OUT,
OKAY, WORK IT OUT.
YEAH.
♪♪♪
ALL RIGHTY,
SO LESLIE IS FIRST.
WHAT I NOTICED WITH YOU
IS THAT YOU DON'T
HIT YOUR POSES STRONG
WHERE WE CAN TELL
THAT YOU'RE POSING,
SO THAT MAKES IT DIFFICULT
FOR A PHOTOGRAPHER
TO CAPTURE IT.
THE REASON WHY
I WANTED ALL THE GIRLS
TO DO THE CATALOG CHALLENGE
IS BECAUSE YOU CAN MAKE
A WHOLE BUNCH OF MONEY
DOING CATALOGS
BECAUSE TIME IS MONEY,
AND THE MORE SHOTS
THAT YOU GET IN THAT DAY,
THE HAPPIER THE CLIENT IS.
TRICKS OF THE TRADE.
SO YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT.
I TALKED TO YOU GUYS THIS WEEK,
EVERYBODY, ABOUT FUTURE GOALS.
WHAT DID YOU WANNA BE AGAIN?
CRIMINAL JUSTICE
INVESTIGATOR.
ALL RIGHT,
SO LET'S SEE HOW YOU LOOKED.
THAT IS A PURE FASHION SHOT
FOR ME.
YOUR BUILD BLEW ME AWAY.
EVERYTHING WAS ELEGANT.
UP NEXT IS DANIELLE.
I ACTUALLY THOUGHT
YOU LOOKED THE GREATEST
IN THE FIREMAN'S OUTFIT.
ALL RIGHTY, SO, DANIELLE,
YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT
WHERE YOU HAD TO LIVE OUT
ONE OF YOUR DREAMS.
AND WHAT WAS THAT?
- A SINGER.
- CAN YOU SING?
I CAN'T EVEN CARRY A TUNE.
(laughs)
WELL, LET US TELL YOU,
SING SOMETHING.
♪ MI, MI, MI ♪
LET'S GO TO THE PICTURE.
(laughter)
VERY SAVAGE,
JUST VERY INTENSE.
IT'S VERY IMAN-DAVID BOWIE.
SHE'S LIKE,
"DAVID, GIVE ME THAT MIC.
I'M-A TRY THIS."
ALL RIGHT, THANK YOU.
UP NEXT IS MOLLIE SUE.
I THINK YOU DEFINITELY WORK,
MOLLIE SUE,
THE EDGY LOOK BEST OF ALL.
THAT'S REALLY YOUR GENRE.
YOU HAVE A CONFIDENCE,
AND THERE'S A SEXINESS TO YOU
THAT I REALLY,
REALLY, REALLY LIKE.
SO YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT
WHERE YOU HAD TO EXPRESS
YOUR FUTURE GOAL AFTER MODELING,
AND THAT IS?
TO BE A MAKEUP ARTIST.
I'LL SAY,
IT'S A VERY MODERN FACE.
YOUR LOOK IS VERY MODERN,
WHICH IS GREAT.
I DON'T FEEL LIKE
YOU PUSH YOURSELF HARD ENOUGH.
I STILL FEEL LIKE
YOU'RE RESTING.
NEXT IS BROOKE.
MISS BROOKE,
90% OF THE JOB IS SHOWING UP,
AND YOU JUST WEREN'T THERE.
I KINDA FROZE UP
AND WENT BLANK, AND I KNOW
I SHOULDN'T HAVE DONE THAT,
BUT I DID.
SO YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT
WHERE YOU HAD TO EXPRESS
YOUR FUTURE GOAL, WHICH WAS...
ANESTHESIOLOGY AND NURSING.
I'M LOOKING AT YOUR FILM,
THIS PICTURE WAS GOOD
AND MAYBE ONE OR TWO OTHER ONES
WERE GOOD.
BUT DON'T BE AFRAID TO BE UGLY.
DON'T BE AFRAID
TO HUNCH YOUR BACK,
TO DO SO MANY DIFFERENT THINGS.
UP NEXT IS JOANIE.
THE CATALOG PICTURES WERE...
I DON'T KNOW WHAT CATALOG
YOU'VE BEEN LOOKING AT.
I TRIED TO DO ALL THE ONES
JANICE TOLD ME TO DO.
I'M SURE SHE TOLD YOU
NOT TO DO IT THAT WAY.
JANICE IS A REALLY GOOD MODEL.
SO, JOANIE,
YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT.
AND... WHAT IS
YOUR FUTURE GOAL?
TO BE A MOM.
A MAMA.
OH, YOU WANNA BE
ONE OF THOSE KIND OF MOMS.
(laughter)
I LOVED YOUR FILM, JOANIE.
IT WAS... SPICY.
LOOK AT HER FACIAL EXPRESSION,
LOOK AT HER EYEBROW.
SHE'S REALLY WORKING HER FACE.
AND YOU DID
SO MANY DIFFERENT EXPRESSIONS.
GREAT PERSONALITY.
IT COMES STRAIGHT ACROSS.
ALL RIGHTY. THANKS.
UP NEXT IS SARA.
AH HA HA HA!
HA HA HA!
(laughter)
BUT...
AS STUPID AS IT SOUNDED,
IF THE PHOTOGRAPHER
WOULD'VE SNAPPED,
IT WAS A GOOD PICTURE.
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
YOU AND JOANIE--
JOANIE DID THE "HA HA HA"
STRANGE.
YOU DID THE "HA HA HA"
THAT JANICE TAUGHT,
AND IT WAS RIGHT.
ALL RIGHTY, SO AFTER MODELING,
WHAT DO YOU WANT TO BE?
A LAWYER.
WELL, I'M SURE
YOU'LL GET HIRED RIGHT AWAY.
(laughs)
THE VERY BEGINNING
OF YOUR FILM
ALMOST LOOKED LIKE A PORNO.
AND THERE'S A FINE LINE,
BECAUSE THIS IS STILL
VERY SEXY, PINUP-Y,
BUT THERE'S A FASHION TWIST
BECAUSE YOUR BODY
IS SLIGHTLY AWKWARD.
ALL RIGHTY, UP NEXT IS JADE.
THERE'S SUCH
A SEXY, SASSY CONFIDENCE
ABOUT YOU THAT I LIKE.
I THINK
YOU LOOK REALLY BEAUTIFUL, JADE,
BUT I THINK WHAT IT IS,
IT LOOKS LIKE A MODEL
THAT'S GOING TO A CLUB.
IT DOESN'T LOOK LIKE A MODEL
THAT IS IN THE MAKING
TO BE DISCOVERED
TO POSSIBLY BE A TOP MODEL.
ALL RIGHT, JADE,
SO YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT
WHERE YOU HAD TO LIVE OUT
YOUR DREAM OF WHAT YOU WANNA BE
AFTER MODELING,
AND THAT IS A WHAT?
A KINDERGARTEN TEACHER,
I LOVE KIDS.
AH! (laughing)
WHAT WOULD I POSSIBLY LEARN
COMING TO SCHOOL,
LOOKING AT YOU LIKE THAT?
I THOUGHT YOU DID A GOOD JOB
BECAUSE YOU WERE BEING HARD
BUT NOT TOO HARD,
WHICH IS THAT THING
THAT YOU'RE STRADDLING.
SO THIS IS VERY STRONG,
BUT IT'S NOT, LIKE,
INTIMIDATING.
ALL RIGHTY, UP NEXT IS GINA.
SO, GINA, HOW DID YOU THINK
YOU DID ON THE POSING?
I DON'T THINK I DID TOO HOT.
(chuckles)
YOU JUST LOOKED
REALLY LOST AND CONFUSED,
AND THEN IT BECAME...
I'VE WRITTEN DOWN, "COMIC POSES,
LIKE ON A BAD COMEDY SHOW."
YOU ALWAYS SEEM A BIT...
INTIMIDATED.
I'M TRYING MY BEST.
I MEAN, THERE'S--
IT'S NOT PERFECT THAT WE'RE--
WHERE WE'RE LIVING RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE THERE'S PROBLEMS
AND STUFF, AND I'M LETTING IT
GET TO ME, OBVIOUSLY.
THE REALITY IS,
YOU'RE IN THE GAME,
SO YOU BETTER STEP UP
TO THE PLATE
AND START PLAYING.
- RIGHT.
SO, GINA, YOU HAD A PHOTO
SHOOT WHERE YOU HAD TO LIVE OUT
YOUR FUTURE GOAL, WHICH IS...
FASHION DESIGN.
JUST GENERALLY SPEAKING,
THIS SHOT IS A LITTLE AWKWARD.
YOU'VE GOT A BEAUTIFUL BODY,
YOU'VE GOT A BEAUTIFUL FACE,
AMAZING CHEEKBONES...
BUT IT SEEMS
YOU'RE JUST SHRINKING AWAY.
- YEAH.
- UP NEXT IS FURONDA.
QUITE FRANKLY, FURONDA,
YOU'VE SURPRISED ME.
YOU HAVE UPPED YOUR GAME.
YOU GAVE SOME ANGLES.
THERE WAS SOME KIND OF ANGLE
YOU WERE DOING.
I LIKE THE ANGLES.
SO YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT
WHERE YOU HAD TO LIVE OUT
YOUR FUTURE GOAL,
AND THAT IS TO BE...
I WANT TO BE
A HUMAN RIGHTS ATTORNEY.
THAT'S A GOOD SHOT,
AND YOU DO LOOK STRONG,
AND IT'S GOOD ANGLES.
I LOVE THE SMOLDERING EYES.
LOOK IT--DO YOU SEE HOW
YOUR EYES ARE SAYING SOMETHING?
ALL RIGHTY, FURONDA,
THANK YOU.
AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST, NNENNA.
YOUR CATALOG POSES WERE SO GOOD.
YOU SMILED
AND YOU THREW YOUR HEAD BACK,
AND IT JUST...
WAS SO APPROACHABLE.
THANK GOD FOR YOUR SMILE,
WHICH, I THINK
IF YOU DIDN'T SMILE,
IT WOULD'VE BEEN
A KIND OF A DUD.
AND YOU WON THE CHALLENGE.
(applause)
- YAY HEY HEY!
ALL RIGHTY, SO, NNENNA,
YOU WANNA BE A WHAT?
CHEMIST,
DRUG RESEARCH IN AFRICA.
MIX THE CHEMICALS,
BECAUSE THE CHEMISTRY IS THERE.
NNENNA,
WHAT WAS UP WITH THIS GUY?
IT GOT FREAKIER AND FREAKIER.
I'M CLICKING THROUGH THE FILM,
IT'S NICE...
THEN HE STANDS UP
AND STANDS BEHIND YOU,
AND THE VERY LAST SHOT
WAS A FRENCH KISS.
- WHAT THE HELL WAS GOING ON?
- OOH!
WAS THERE A CONNECTION
WITH THE TWO OF YOU?
I THINK WE HAD CHEMISTRY.
NNENNA,
YOU CAN ALSO ALWAYS SAY "NO."
NNENNA WAS NOT TRYING
TO SAY "NO" IN THAT PICTURE.
SHE WAS SAYING, "YES! YES!"
BRING IT ON!
I HAVE A BOYFRIEND.
NOT ANYMORE, YOU DON'T!
YOU HAD A BOYFRIEND,
SWEETHEART.
NOT IN THAT SHOT.
SO NOW IT'S TIME
FOR THE JUDGES TO DELIBERATE,
AND AFTER THAT I'LL CALL
YOU BACK, AND I WILL ANNOUNCE
WHICH ONE OF YOU
WILL BE ELIMINATED.
♪♪♪
ALL RIGHTY, SO NOW IT'S TIME
FOR US TO DELIBERATE AND DECIDE
WHICH ONE OF THESE SWEET BABIES
HAS TO GO HOME TODAY.
GINA.
I THINK THERE'S
SOMETHING SPECIAL THERE,
BUT HER PERSONAL STUFF
IS HOLDING HER BACK.
BUT THIS PICTURE'S...
SHE LOOKS ABSOLUTELY STUNNING.
YOU CAN'T DENY THE FACE.
YEAH,
LESLIE.
LESLIE, FOR ME,
IS JUST NOT BRINGING IT HOME.
SHE TAKES BEAUTIFUL PICTURES,
I THINK YOU GUYS JUST SEE HER
STANDING LIKE THIS
IN THE JUDGING.
JADE.
JADE'S LEARNING.
SHE'S LISTENING.
AT LEAST SHE'S PUTTING IT ON
TO GET THE GIG.
EXACTLY.
WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT SHE DOING AT HOME.
THIS IS A COMPETITION.
THIS IS NOT "AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP BEST FRIEND."
BROOKE.
BIZARRELY ENOUGH,
BROOKE'S MANAGED TO SURVIVE
THROUGH ALL OF HER INADEQUACIES.
HOW BROOKE LOOKS IN PERSON
TO ME LOOKS LIKE TOP MODEL,
BUT HER FACE
IS NOT PHOTOGRAPHING
LIKE WHAT I SEE IN PERSON.
SARA.
IN THE BEGINNING,
I REALLY LOVED SARA.
I LOVED HER HEIGHT.
SHE WAS PECULIAR TODAY.
DANIELLE.
SHE'S LISTENING,
SHE'S TAKEN NOTE
AND SHE'S PROGRESSING.
I MEAN, IT'S A GREAT PICTURE.
MOLLIE SUE.
IF MOLLIE SUE
CAN GET SOME FIRE,
I THINK SHE CAN GO QUITE FAR.
NNENNA.
THIS ISN'T MY FAVORITE
PHOTOGRAPH,
BUT I DO LIKE NNENNA.
EACH WEEK THAT SHE COMES,
I AM JUST BORED TO DEATH.
(laughter)
NNENNA'S POWERFUL IN PHOTOS,
AND SHE'S POWERFUL IN PERSON,
BUT IT'S A QUIET POWER.
JOANIE.
I LOVE THIS PHOTOGRAPH.
SHE SURPRISED ME
BECAUSE THERE'S PERSONALITY,
THERE'S WIT, THERE'S SEXINESS.
FURONDA.
YOU CAN TELL THAT SHE'S LIKE,
"I'M REALLY IN THIS,
AND I WANNA WIN THIS."
I THINK PERSONALITY IS KEY,
I LIKE HER.
THE PROBLEM THAT I HAVE
WITH FURONDA,
SOMETIMES I THINK HER HEAD
IS SHAPED LIKE LIGHTBULB.
SO'S MINE.
MY WHOLE FAMILY CALLS ME
"LIGHTBULB HEAD."
SHE HAS A BRIGHT FUTURE
AHEAD OF HER.
(laughing)
♪♪♪
TEN GIRLS STAND BEFORE ME,
BUT I ONLY HAVE NINE PHOTOS
IN MY HANDS.
AND THESE PHOTOS REPRESENT
THE NINE OF YOU THAT
WILL STILL BE IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE FIRST NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL...
FURONDA.
YOU HAVE COME A LONG WAY.
LOOK AT THIS PICTURE,
IT'S A STRIKING PICTURE
AND A CONFIDENT GIRL.
CONGRATULATIONS,
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE NEXT NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL...
JOANIE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
THANKS.
DANIELLE.
LESLIE.
JADE.
JADE'S GETTING BETTER AND BETTER
EVERY WEEK WITH THESE JUDGES.
JUST GET A LITTLE BIT MORE
SWEETNESS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THANK YOU
FOR BELIEVING IN ME.
THE NEXT NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL...
MOLLIE SUE.
SARA.
CONGRATULATIONS.
THE NEXT NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL...
NNENNA.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THANK YOU.
WILL BROOKE AND GINA
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
I ONLY HAVE ONE PHOTO
IN MY HANDS,
AND THIS PHOTO REPRESENTS
THE GIRL THAT WILL
STILL BE IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
I'LL CALL ONLY ONE NAME.
THE GIRL THAT I DO NOT CALL
MUST IMMEDIATELY
RETURN TO THE HOUSE,
PACK YOUR BAGS,
AND YOU GO HOME.
BROOKE,
YOU'RE THE GIRL THAT THE JUDGES
LOOK AT AS HAVING
ALL THE POTENTIAL IN THE WORLD.
THE JUDGES ARE SAYING,
"WHEN DOES POTENTIAL STOP
AND TRUE TALENT START?"
GINA, YOUR FACE
IS ONE OF THE FAVORITE FACES
OF THE JUDGES.
THEY CONSTANTLY TALK ABOUT
YOUR HIGH CHEEKBONES,
BUT THEY FEEL LIKE
THERE'S SOMETHING
THAT'S A LITTLE VACUOUS,
THAT DOESN'T CONNECT.
SO WHO GOES HOME?
WITH POTENTIAL,
THERE'S POSSIBILITIES, BROOKE.
- CONGRATULATIONS.
- THANK YOU.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU, GINA.
♪♪♪
(chuckles)
MODELING IS
DEFINITELY A LOT HARDER THAN
A LOT OF PEOPLE MIGHT THINK.
I'M SAD BECAUSE I KNOW
I COULD'VE DONE SO MUCH BETTER.
I'VE LEARNED THAT
NOT EVERYONE WILL LIKE ME,
NO MATTER HOW FRIENDLY I AM.
THERE'S ALWAYS GOING
TO BE OBSTACLES IN MY LIFE,
AND IT'S UP TO ME
TO FIGURE LIFE OUT ON MY OWN.
♪♪♪
COMING UP
ON "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,"
THE GIRLS HAVE SOME FUN
WITH NICK CANNON UNTIL JADE
TAKES A JOKE TOO FAR...
MY SKIN IS FLAWLESS,
AND YOU LOOK REALLY LUMPY.
STARRING IN A COVER GIRL AD
TURNS OUT TO BE NOT SO EASY...
MY GOD.
AND A SHOCKING COLLAPSE...
- OH, MY GOD!
- ARE YOU OKAY?
CATCHES EVERYONE
BY SURPRISE.
OH, MY GOD.
♪♪♪